foreign
representative Katie Porter okay who's
uh you know a fat liberal Democrat woman
oh okay um
well bill has a little fun with her okay
unfortunate name
the Civil debate nobody
including Riley Gaines who I disagree
with strongly should be disagree with
out of interest
um I I think that it should be up to
sporting bodies to make the decisions
about who what if she said that's
actually wrong
I think that what she has done is try to
turn this we talked about people you
know becoming using things to kind of
get likes and get clicks that's not what
she's doing I've got no truck right
against personally but all I've seen her
do is stand up for women's rights to
fairness and equality she actually
competed against Leah Thomas and it was
obviously unfair Leah Thomas won one of
the races in the NCAA championships by
50 seconds against a bunch of biological
females 50 seconds think about that's a
lot a big gap you simply couldn't keep
up that cannot be wrong competitions are
won by like like [__] fractions yeah
they're always like a kind hair yeah
yeah literally and not be fair
that I trust I think our sporting bodies
should be dealing with and by the way
and she's bringing then but she's well
Riley doing what's pointing out that
they're not but what happens when like a
Florida sporting body decides the
opposite thing is what we're gonna do or
like a North Dakota or South Dakota yeah
we're not going to let that happen you
guys all of a sudden start shrieking
autistically at them
so you don't leave it up to the sporting
bodies
one to two seconds is fine but like 50
60 seconds you did beat him by a lot it
is 50 seconds is a lot Riley is speaking
up for herself
and that is her prerogative and I
respect her free speech I think she's
speaking up for pretty much every female
athlete in the world
Pierce is right
and the last thing that came close their
piece the the last good thing that was
near Pierce's mouth was when Jeremy
Clarkson punched him in it
yes you know you you guys are in a bad
position now because now even the
[__] the Bill Maher crowd is starting
to clap which is you're starting to lose
your [__] liberal dudes now and the
Bill Maher crowd tends to be the crowd
that gives the money it is it's at that
the elite that stuffy it's Upper West
Side liberal is the ones that like Bill
Maher right I mean wasn't that wasn't
that the point of Title IX Title IX in
the early 70s was something that was a
it was a major event in feminism that we
finally have this law that says at
colleges right and I think high schools
do but definitely colleges women women
sports have to be given equal to men's
sports so that women aren't you know by
the way remember when that was the
reasonable liberals and you could be
like okay and you know I don't agree
with everything but I kind of see like
merch pointed this out and it was
something that was so stupid but it was
something that I've really hopped Beyond
The Pale like we were in Austin We're in
the elevator and I brought this up
before but it just really made me think
about it was like he goes they had like
hey recycle your bags on Tuesday and
Marissa goes remember when this is the
only Annoying Thing we had to deal with
the Liberals was then when they were
being reasonable like hey recycle yeah
remember when they were they literally
it used to just be like Lisa Simpson
liberals yeah like they were kind of
annoying recycle okay
yeah I can put up the Captain Planet
occasionally exactly slept in the WNBA
and lots of other stuff this seems to be
the opposite of that it seems to be so
many instances I think where wokeness is
the opposite of what I grew up as
liberalism was let's give the women an
equal shot yeah but you have created
again yes we always have the prefaces oh
you did this we always hit the Prevacid
it's fine great that you're saying this
stuff now but you helped us this is
let's put a mail in the in the swimming
pool with the women I don't get it it's
crazy and meanwhile trans people who
genuinely want to compete at Athletics
and swimming or whatever it may be they
they're the ones who are suffering here
they need to be found a way to compete
fairly and justly what's your answer
then I think there's one or two answers
but I mean that's easy the answer is
already there either you give them their
own [__] League
or they compete with the sex they were
born in I mean that's pretty simple
right like that's not like she's making
it this this [__] this [__] fat
titted heifer over here not pierce the
other one is making it seem like like
there's not a simple solution there's a
really simple one and we're we're all
the female to male basketball players
and football players when are we gonna
get to see them because it's the same
thing right no it's not it's different
get me no get me get me a couple female
males and throw them out on an NFL field
we need this just to prove a point all
the female to male [__] are too busy
uh trying on their Dickies and turning
their [__] baseball caps backwards no
no let's get them playing sports let's
cart a couple of you [__] completely
shattered bodies off the [__] field
on National Television right maybe
people will start getting the [__]
point
yeah let Vince Wilfork run into some
five foot four [__] girl who used to
be a frail tomboy
[__] mutant League that's great get
out there Elliott page yeah come on
logical sex as many of them did before
or you create an entirely new category
so we're transgender
and then they're able to compete fairly
but what you cannot do is continue to
allow more and more trans athletes to
start decimating women's records in some
cases irrevocably it's just not fair
and then let me clip I said though that
was that was a lead up I guess to them
oh okay I I just go to Facebook right
now I thought I grabbed I thought hold
on sorry
uh hear it yeah because the one I
grabbed didn't go as viral but it was
way better as far as watching this woman
get beat up and I think it's got some
Boomer recorded it off the TV okay
yeah you sound kind of fat
sorry
yeah
you are immature that's why they were
kids not a 21. not all over the world
they're a different mature that's why we
don't well you're using another 21
that's why some of us don't think that
20 year olds or 19 year olds ought to be
able to go get AR-15 or vote well just
wait for it okay they can go fight I
think they're already in the Army well I
think that's a discussion we should have
because I think we know about it I
thought of your vote you should be able
to have a certain level of maturity
they're deciding whether you should be
in Congress or not well
this is where it starts to get
this is where it starts to get a little
let's see where it starts to get a
little nasty
watch her break watch her watch him
break her I
the immature first of all immaturity
that was
Rocky IV when it's [__] when the
Russian's eye gets cut open yeah you
know what I mean it's like oh [__]
watch her
I thought you said I was all right
spider
man
there's not necessarily an age thing you
can be immature well you just played the
age card yeah you were like our argument
sucks because we're old but Jesus he's
like is this like [__] this is like a
four piece in a Biscuit going on right
now she said she made a nasty little
thing I tried to do a little sassy girl
mode should I do an okay Boomer and it
pissed him off so much that he was like
oh okay
I didn't say that I was getting so
boring by the way look at people
can I just look at Pierce face real
quick just look at his eyes when we go
back from just real quick we're old but
just I didn't say that it's getting so
boring by the way
he's like oh boy
[Music]
[Applause]
shouldn't we critique each other on the
content of our ideas not on those
identity
yeah I bro I'm sorry I thought we were
on the left that's exactly what we do
we've been trying to do that for years
you just said that you win the immature
votes so she's like you're the one that
called them mature you [__] [__]